pops
would you please stand
[Applause]
I started this off thanking you
and I want to end it the same way
I owe you a debt of gratitude and I'll
never be able to repay
when I would cry and say I can't
you made me go harder
you pushed me to limits
that I didn't know were inside of me
the hard work I put in was because I
didn't want to let you down
those countless hours in the backyard we
would compete against each other like
strangers
and built me to last
those days that turned into late nights
of me working on my left hand
so it was just as good as my right
it made me an Unstoppable Force
that time you got kicked out of the game
as my coach
and snuck back in the side door
and Coach me from the stands
just to get kicked out again
it showed me that there was no
limitations on how you would show up for
me
it's the exact same way I try to show it
for my kids
so even though I hated being called
little Dwayne
I admired you as a kid
I admire you now
we had the same exact dream
and we carry same exact name
Dwayne Tyrone Wade
to know we Hustle
all the way to the Basketball Hall of
Fame is God's will
so pops
I know your knees a little sore
but will you join me on stage
as we take our rightful step
into basketball heaven
[Applause]
this one right here
this one is for my father
I love you and I'm thankful for you
I love you too man
we're in the Hall of Fame dog
foreign